[Music]
so my air pods max have arrived i
ordered
the silver and the pink these were the
ones that apple sent me to review
and marquez i just want to say i'm so
sorry maybe they got our addresses mixed
up or something i'm not
sure or maybe they just thought that you
know your new favorite color
should be green either way you guys
should actually go check out marquez's
video he just posted it talking about
the new airpods pro max so this isn't
going to be any crazy in-depth review
it's actually
very late right now let's go back and
take my dog to the vet and these were
sitting on my doorstep but i really just
wanted to show you
the colors of all of these but i've been
using them
every single day for phone calls for
zoom calls conference calls
i've been using them for gaming i use
them this weekend to shoot my podcast
with my sister
i've been editing with them i did a
running class with them
on apple fitness i also kind of started
to do a yoga class
just for the sake of the video and i
realized that doing yoga in over-the-ear
headphones no matter what type
they are is not really very enjoyable
i have done yoga though with just the
regular air pods and those work great
i absolutely love these i love the way
that they look
on camera i love the way that they sound
when i'm editing i love the way that
i was using them with the road caster
with the plug-in lightning cable to 3.5
millimeter headphone jack which i do
think is a little bit expensive
obviously i don't love the price they
are
very expensive but these are incredibly
high quality headphones you are
paying for them to sound incredible to
look amazing and when i first tried out
that spatial audio
it really did make me feel like a jedi
now let's
turn it on okay now it's on oh my gosh
it's like i'm in the mandalorian right
now
hold that thought
try spatial audio once
becomes a jedi very quickly
i do want to do a follow-up video after
i've really had a chance to really test
these out extensively
but for the most part i am so happy with
my purchase
i got these for mine and my sister's
podcast so that she can have a set and i
can have
a set oh this just looks so good this is
also kind of exciting because now i can
mix and match the ear cups as well so
we're gonna dress these up and do a
little mix and match with the ear cups
first let's just open
these up this is something that tyler
pointed out earlier uh
when he was here the box is a one-to-one
scale
of the headphones another thing that i
kind of wish that they would have
is the 3.5 millimeter cables
to match each headset because they only
have white and black but i want this
cable
to match this color maybe there's some
third-party ones out and if there aren't
hello third-party can you can you work
on that please i would also like it to
be a
thicker cable a little bit more
industrial because the apple one
is kind of thin i'm worried that if i
ever do start traveling again
or if i'm using them on a daily basis
like it's a very thin cable also marquez
in this video oh my god he does not like
this case
at all it looks like a little purse i
can't wait
to see this pink oh wow
oh hello it's more of like a salmon
color and this is actually
i wouldn't say it's my favorite color
because i really love hot pink but like
as an
accent color and just a color to wear in
general
love this love everything
about this look at this look at that
freaking pink is beautiful this is
beautiful
get ready oh hello
back up everybody stop what you're doing
the hype
train has left the station look at that
look at that look at that so one of the
things that a lot of
early reviewers have said is that these
are a heavier pair of headphones
and they're not wrong these are heavier
than most normal pair
of higher end kind of luxury headphones
but
the way that they have kind of evened it
out to make this weight
distribute over the top of your head
with this little mesh band
is pretty good look at that look at you
look at you you look
so good so color comparison compared to
the space gray
um they just look like macaroons like i
can't get over it
like they just look like a delicious
macaroon
that i would like to eat right now oh
what a weird case
it's just like this is something that
they decided that was
what they were gonna do i'm actually
like totally fine with this case
i just wish that it had something to
protect this band because if i ever
start traveling again
i don't want this to be exposed to the
outside world
can i like put it in no i can't i take
this apart like what can i do to
make this better look at this this
silver looks
fresh like a fresh snowfall
on a winter's day i wonder how soon it's
going to be until apple releases a new
type of case for these
hopefully soon to be honest with you
wow okay
the white is very
very pretty this is so good looking
it is like a beautiful snowfall i can't
even tell which ones are my favorite
like these also look incredible
i think if i had to pick one pair i
think it'd be the white no i like that
no i think it's the white i think i
would pick the white
only because when i'm doing live streams
and things like this
these kind of blend in to my background
and i like being able to see them
so this oh shoot who is she
she is me
i'm really really happy right now one of
the things i've noticed using this over
the past
couple of days is how amazing the
transparency mode is and how easy it is
to hop
right into it you just press this top
little button right here that
automatically brings you into the
transparency mode so you can hear
everything around you
i'm so confused sometimes when i hear
myself talking because it's so clear
it's almost like i'm not wearing
anything over my ears it's
really really impressive as far as the
noise cancelling goes it's also
pretty impressive i mean i can't even
hear myself talking when i have the
volume all the way up
i do love being able to have this
physical dial and because this is
so similar to the apple watch it kind of
ties everything into the apple ecosystem
design wise and i also love the pink as
well but if i had to pick
i mean this is a look this is this is
definitely a statement
and this is just subtle let's do a
little mix and match
of these ear cups oh okay can you even
tell
barely
[Music]
not that into it i think i like the
white cups the best look at that that's
nice
yeah yeah you know
these look good the white on the black
now that's cool
it's hard to tell especially with my
longer hair like you can't really
see it as much on people probably with
shorter hair
i think that we are going to keep the
ear cups
how apple has intended them but it is
nice to know
that if you want to mix and match it's
possible thank you guys so much for
watching i hope you enjoyed this quick
look at some of the newer colors for the
airpods max i look forward to using
these in
all of my future videos for editing for
podcasting
or all of the things if you guys have
any questions feel free to leave them in
the comments below and hopefully that i
and hopefully i can answer those for you
if you haven't subscribed to my channel
already be sure to do so and for those
of you that have subscribed thank you so
much and thank you for coming along on
this really fun journey this year it's
been a
really crazy year but i appreciate all
of you guys in the comments and on
twitter and on instagram and everywhere
we get to hang out
so i'm gonna go edit this video and see
you guys in the next one
you're not gonna tell me that this
doesn't look like a set of macaroons
like in a nice little
delicious bakery setting
hey siri play the new taylor swift album